then by the way we shouldn't be afraid
of the word feminist men and women
should use it to describe themselves
anytime they want men have to be a big
part of this conversation one of the
things I'm incredibly proud to have a
partner in my wife Sophie who is
extremely committed to women girls
issues of a like my nan and I agree with
her on that and and I've been very
thoughtful but how we raise our daughter
but she caught me yeah she took me aside
a few months ago and said okay it's
great that you're engaged and modeling
to your daughter that you want her in
power and everything but you need to
take as much effort to talk to your sons
my eight year old boy my two year old so
little young still about how he treats
women and how he is going to be grow up
to be a feminist just like dad and by
the way we shouldn't be afraid of
use it to describe themselves anytime
they want that that role we have as men
in supporting and demanding equality
demanding a shift is really really
important